qu'arthur clément au médecin biologiste
gérant des laboratoires clément et
membre du bureau du syndicat des jeunes
biologistes médicaux
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france la haute autorité a donc
autorisé aujourd'hui lusage de ces tests
antigénique s est ce une bonne chose
où en est-on d'ailleurs des engorgements
d'élaborer plusieurs questions oui c'est
une bonne chose
effectivement d'utiliser les tests quand
il est dit qu elle reste encore un petit
point à déterminer sur leur efficacité
donc l'utilisation ou vera mots quel
cadre elle sera faite parce que comme
vous le disiez dans votre deuxième
question il ya actuellement un
engorgement des la bouquinette moment
très important que ce qu'on a pu
connaître ces dernières semaines c'est
vraiment adapté à cette demande
croissante
on a été un peu surpris par une demande
très importante du nombre de textes a
réalisé un début septembre
c'est actuellement encore en croissance
mais une croissance plus faible donc
l'amour puisse adapter et la
quasi-totalité des labos ont la
possibilité de rendre des résultats en
moins de 80 actuellement ce qui est
clairement un timing qui est compatible
avec la gestion dans cette crise
sanitaire
c'est ce que vous constatez où il ya
encore des files d'attentes un je vous
le confirme dans les labos et des
résultats qui ne sont pas encore rendus
sous 24 heures
est-ce que vous avez une proportion de
deux labos qui rentre dans les 24 heures
et qui n'ont plus de ces d'attenté
d'ailleurs comment ont-ils fait pour ne
plus en avoir
la source du vin du ministère de la
santé oms et le milieu des rangs qui a
dit que 80 % les résultats étaient
rendus en moins de 48 heures il n'a pas
donné les chiffres sur 24 heures
donc je les ai pas moi parce que je peux
de ce que je constate en tout cas dans
un laboratoire annonce fonctionne sur
rendez vous ce qui nous permet d'éviter
des files d'attentes très importante
certains n'est contraire laboratoire
fonctionne également sur rendez vous ce
qui leur permet de contrôler les flux
également les flux de patients à
l'intérieur des laboratoires dans cette
période automnale avec l'idée qu'ils
s'approchent où les gens vont être plus
à l'intérieur que sur la première
n'était plus de 120 ans donc oui les ans
voire d'être d'accord dans certains
laboratoires mais malgré tout elle
diminue donc s'attendre à laver alors
vous détendre on va prendre rendez vous
concrètement on sait qu'il faut aller
vite quand on les a attendus du coc vide
on prend rendez vous et on a le
rendez-vous dans la journée alors c'est
pendant quelques cas de figure vous elle
mais pour les passions qui sont
prioritaires
donc les listes de passagers
prioritaires ont été a clairement défini
las pour les patients symptomatiques les
patients qui ont une ordonnance
également les patients aucun pacte de
patients confirmés positifs c'est à dire
tous les patients pour lesquels les
résultats des textes vraiment aider à
casser les chaînes de transmission pour
ces patients là on les prend dans des
délais qui sont très courts c'est-à-dire
en moins d'une journée
l'objectif qui nous a été fixée nous au
laboratoire par les talents tribunal de
santé c'est de fixer un rendez-vous dans
la journée aux patients et de leur
donner un résultat dans la journée
suivante détendre résultats également
plus court vous l'avez des diamants pour
ça s'explique comment est-ce qu'il ya
moins de demande du fait que ce soient
priorisées aujourd'hui le fait que les
protocoles échanger également dans les
écoles est ce que ça un petit peu réduit
le nombre de tests alors il ya un tout
petit peu moins de demandes que la
semaine dernière mais ça reste moi-même
d'egypte qui sont assez importants avec
plus de 20 millions 200 mille tests par
semaine versus 1 million 300 mille la
semaine précédente les délais en analyse
qui ont diminué est tout simplement dû
au fait est ce que les laboratoires ont
dû s'équiper et est aussi recruter de
nouvelles personnes pour pouvoir nous
aider et que ce temps est incompressible
et notamment on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver des automates et
des réactifs qui sont des produits qui
sont un produit justement à l'étranger
et donc il a fallu y avait forcément des
délais d'attenté entre la commande et la
livraison contenu également accueilli
une demande qu'ils soient très
importante au niveau international et
donc le fait que
laboratoires ont dû attendre ses
livraisons à retarder et le rendu des
analyses maintenant que nous allons en
train de nous équiper chaque laboratoire
petit à petit la permis à l'échelle
nationale ou l'amant de réduire les
délais des tests et ce sont toujours les
tests pcr qui sont évidemment la
priorité pour le pour le patient a eu le
mandat
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas passer au test
pour avoir une réponse en 30 minutes
pourquoi ne pas le généraliser ce test
antigénique tout simplement parce que
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle
l'état tant de génie qui effectivement
l'avantagé d'être d'avoir un rendu qui
est plus rapide puisque la technique en
elle-même est plus un malheureusement
s'étaient sentis génique actuellement
nous papéa propres total de leur
efficacité par rapport à ce test pcr
dans le nez qui reste actuellement le
test de référence sur le marché et donc
dans un dans un contexte où le résultat
du test est extrêmement important on ne
devrait pas si vous voulez promet de
proposer à des patients un test dont les
résultats ne seraient pas fiables ont
souhaité proposer le plus fiable au
patient et c'est pour cette raison que
le test pcr actuellement reste le le
test de référence pour pour la lutte
contre la propagation du virus
vous nous confirmer le test pcr n'est
pas non plus fiable à 100% il peut y
avoir des ce qu'on appelle des faunes et
guettent des faux négatifs et aider des
faux positifs encore oui tout à fait il
faut savoir que en médecine rien n'est
100% tanneux ça n'existe pas vraiment
donc il ya forcément des faux négatifs
et des faux positifs
ils sont malgré tout il faut le dire
pour rassurer vos téléspectateurs ils
sont relativement faibles et faux
négatifs ils sont surtout dus à la
qualité du prélèvement on est très
vigilant au fait que les préleveurs
soient bien formés et notamment qu'il
réalise un geste qui est suffisamment
profond pour récupérer in greece là où
il pourrait se focaliser ce qui permet
de diminuer sensiblement le taux de faux
négatifs ou trop positifs il est lié à
une sensibilité très importante des
machines permet de détecter la moindre
molécule
râle et pour sa éléments on s'adapte et
des fournisseurs à berthe le nom de
cycle qui permet de rendre un état
positif
on a actuellement un taux de faux
positifs que négatifs qui est très
ce qui fait que ce test reste encore à
l'heure actuelle le test de référence
dans la lutte contre le corps d'un virus
dont globalement depuis la mi septembre
depuis l'annnonce de jean castex de
prioriser ces tests voulais qu'ils
travaillent et justement dans les
laboratoires pour vous la situation
s'est améliorée
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait encore amélioré
pour être efficace dans la lutte contre
le virus
alors en fait pour la poursuite de la
priorisation n'avait pas attendu une
annonce de jean castex pour les pour les
mettre en place notre instinct médical
nous avait poussés à prendre en charge
des patients qui étaient symptomatiques
les actions de graves allégations urgent
avant les autres forcément cette du
ministre du premier ministre simplement
confirmer quelque chose qui était déjà
fait dans les laboratoires il y avait
deux types de frein à l'époque ces deux
types de frein que l'on rencontre encore
actuellement pour répondre à la deuxième
partie de la question
ces deux types de frein que l'on a
évoqué plus tôt ce sont à la fois le pet
de s'approvisionner en réactifs et en
automatique machines qui permettent de
faire le test est également le pen
d'avoir suffisamment une béquille nul à
lapoutroie les secrétaires pour
enregistrer les dossiers également des
préleveurs des fermiers ou techniciens
de laboratoire pouvoir faire les
prélèvements et les techniciens d'abord
accord pour réaliser l'analyse en
elle-même il faut qu'on ait plus de
personnes ils équipent leurs plus de
gens impliqués pour qu'on puisse
travailler plus efficacement
donc pour traiter plus de patients dans
des délais plus courts merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions arthur
clément merci d'avoir été l'invité
d'arreter france ce soir